this is a production of Cornell
University
I wanted to thank you to thank my
students and this is what our group
meetings look like on the left side of
the screen
it was either cubby halls or meeting in
Central Park when the situation seems to
alleviate
before the next variant showed up
but also I particularly I wanted to
highlight
um the the individuals here who
contributed
through the research
Kimberly Gibson Sarah dolli
uh and then Stephanie Zulo are students
of mine
they are now off to better things they
have graduated
Medina is a student of
Gilbert and uh physiology
and Santos Barrera who also contributed
a few of the slides
was a long time
researcher at seat and he then recently
obtained PhD at the University of
Nebraska you know collaboration
so
I will
this is kind of a brief overview of my
program
skip that
I would like to outline
my talk is that and uh
it's well timed because the iccp
or ipcc came with that latest report and
it's as
uh troublesome as ever
and we don't seem to be doing anymore
so I
would like to talk about a briefly
introduce the topic they need to
increase
and speed up John plasma utilization
another
I think that a lot of people are doing
this but the target seems to be
ever more complex
I'll introduce then the model I'm
talking about this is inspired by
research on domestication hotspot phase
always with our seven domestications
I'll explain this to you and then two of
these domesticates are temporary bean
and lima beans
and they may help us in this dire
situation
and then I'll end with a summary
so it's clear that you know we have been
putting out CO2 and other greenhouse
gases
um
not slowing at a rate that is not
slowing down
if you see this in the left part
um
but also
we have benefited
and this is the domestication work that
shows from a relatively stable climate
for the last 10 000 years
and except then what you're right at the
end you see a an ever increasing
temperature
[Music]
and we have to deal with that
the issue will not go away even if we
were to stop right now all the CO2
emissions and other greenhouse gases
because you see the difference here
I think I also talked to zoom
the the two curves here this is the
emissions if we take the best case
scenario where we stop all the uh
emissions as fast as possible the light
blue line here
the CO2 content of the atmosphere is
barely going to decrease
so we are set with a continued
continually he
heated uh climate all over the Earth
and we see the consequences also for a
long time people have said well where is
this uh global climate change
and as recently I think there was an
article in the New York Times that
questioned that
to stay out of U.S politics the French
president said you have never told us
that we were going to be faced with
these catastrophes and so on upon which
the French media put together a clip
where they they listed almost several
instances dating back to the 1970s where
they said hey we are going to we are
faced with global climate change and
certainly Global media okay
um
so
to give a recent example here
at the left this is what the situation
in California in September of last year
not very long ago
this is the situation now in March
and we see a radical change in terms of
the drought status
I would say a drought improve
Improvement of the drought status in the
state and it's not finished
they are expecting another atmospheric
River this this week and it's going to
affect mostly Central and Southern
California
okay we can say that this is a
consequence of global warming
of the the oceans
so how do we deal with this Heating and
this irregular precipitation
we are going to be faced with drought
and just to simplify because it's going
to come back later on there are at least
two types major types of graduated the
one in the middle intermittent drought
where you have irregular rainfall and so
the crops have to be faced with
sufficient water insufficient water in
succession and then at the bottom you
see the terminal drought where the crop
is grown as a consequence or based on
the residual moisture in the soil and so
when we talk about drought we have to at
least Define these two big classes of
drought and I will talk mostly about the
2D intermittent throughout the internal
drugs for that but this is from a work
by Fisher who was talking about rice
okay so this is an issue that goes
across or crops also
yeah
now the second theme is that
we have these Gene Banks they have been
established all over the world USDA has
an important germplasm system I would
say that it's probably
the biggest and if not the most
successful one
but one limitation is
the the use of it the lack of thereof
and also the speed at which we use these
accessions in a gene Bank
and so
I will focus primarily here
on this aspect here The Germ plasm how
do we get it into the current breeding
Cycles
now
I've been working on physiologists for
quite some time starting at the gene
bank at a gene Bank in Seattle Colombia
and the predictions here is you see here
this is a work of Ramirez caral and it
shows the optimum versus less Optimum
areas
in principally I would say here in South
America and in Africa and I highlight
these regions because they are so
important in the nutrition
oh
um local people
if they people haven't eaten beans they
probably think they haven't eaten at all
and its beans and rice beans and Maize
and so on
now if we look at the predictions for
the future
in the Americas and in Africa you see
that this suitable area which is the
green area is shrinking
with the current materials and in the
current way of growing these crops
so to this is an incentive actually to
look what can we do when faced with this
hit the increased heat and also the
irregularity of the precipitation
right
so the genus physiologist itself
has five domesticated species they have
been known for some time
you have common being which is by far
the most important one
you have Runner Bean which is the
closest or close relative
you have the so-called year being which
is the least known of the five
domesticates uh predominantly in Central
America
but you also didn't have these two other
species temporary beam
and
lima bean
what we have found is that
two of those species have been
domesticated twice
in Mexico and in the southern Andes
and lima bean again in Mexico
and in the Andes but in a very
restricted area on the western slope of
the Andes in Ecuador in Northern Peru
and interestingly that area also has
these wild common being but those were
not domesticated and there is an
altitude difference Lima beanies on the
lower altitudes and common Bean is at a
higher altitude and so it's almost like
people made a choice
and they domesticated lima bean rather
than common B
in that area
now our differences why is it that
people
domesticated these different species
what you see on the screen is the
distribution of the wild ancestor
from the left you see common B that has
the broadest distribution
uh lima bean is close also it involves
this migration in both species from the
area of origin of the genus
to Central America and then most
importantly to the Andes and there are
several breakpoints that are naturally
determined lima bean has pretty much the
same distribution but it's a in terms of
genetic relatedness it's somewhat
different then you have Runner being
you have the stepory beam which is
concentrated in you could say the
Northwest quadrants of Mexico and also
the southwest of the U.S principally
Arizona and then the year being has a
very narrow distribution the wild
ancestor in Guatemala and this is
probably caused to because of the fact
that it's a hybrid state stabilized
hybrid between Runner bean and commonly
okay
so these are the three Gene pools in
common Bean and the red one and the blue
one have been domesticated to not the
yellow one
so these are again the seven
domestications you see at the top row is
the wild relative very small seeds
camouflaged
uh and then the the next row are the
domesticated seeds and you see a
tremendous change in size and color and
so on
now another thing that differentiates
them is their adaptation
the most important species here Human
Bean and I say economically at this
stage is uh growing in an intermediate
environment not too hot not too cold not
too dry not too wet
on the left of it are the species that
are adapted to a cooler more humid
environment
which on the face of it might not be
useful in a
in a scenario of
global climate change but who knows
if we want to plant earlier to adapt
be spacious to
global warming maybe we'll have to plant
earlier into a cooler season so this is
not that they are not useful but for now
we don't concentrate on them on the
right you have lima bean and temporary
bean and they are adapted to drier
and other climates
it's definitely the case for temporary
Bean for Lima Bean this is a species
with a very with the broadest adaptation
in Mexico
another aspect that we have
studied
is the domestication syndrome what are
the morphological differences and
physiological differences between
wild and domesticated types in common
being mainly and
I emphasize these traits because they
are still useful today this is not a
matter of the past ten thousand years
ago
they affect the product productivity and
the quality of these crops
even today
um
you have a number of characters here for
seeds and part colors and weight knowing
the color is extremely important in
terms of consumer acceptability
if it's not the right color people will
not accept it
and I'm not just talking about red or
yellow
no it's a particular shade of red
or a particular shade of yellow
so the consumer especially in the
Americas less so in Africa are extremely
how would I say uh
recognizing
picky if I could say about the the color
of these of these
the first actually character
domestication that we ident Gene for
domestication was the determinacy which
creates a bush beam
and
um
it is actually the gene responsible is a
homologue of arabidopsis
and it has three copies
in the genome in the bin genome and one
of them is where most of the mutations
the loss of function mutations for these
genes were identified it is also we took
took care of the opportunity in order to
demonstrate that he was really the gene
we transformed arabidopsis with a
functional allele of the the homolog in
beans actually and we were able to
restore the wild type phenotype in
arabidopsis
but so this Gene is important in the
bush production of green beans because
it's uh shortens the flowering time and
making Harvest easier
for the period sensitivity you will see
is tremendously important especially in
terms of John plasma utilization
is a semi-tropical Genus adapted to
um short days or long nights and when we
plant them
in temperate areas many of these
succession don't flower
so it affects utilization the screening
of John plasm as well and there are two
genes that have been identified
based on the materials that we had
distributed but by to Jim Weller in
Australia and Martha santaya in in Spain
see dormancy is also important and it
has to do with the permeability of the
seed coat and the composition in terms
of waxes
and then more recently
uh Travis Parker
was a student and now postdoc and now
researcher at Davis
um
studied the development of the pod in
during domestication so our first step
was to eliminate or reduce Cloud
shattering
again this is a trait that is still
important today
um and he also then studied the absence
of
threads or strings that people call we
talk about string bees so the modern
green beans don't have a string and this
he was able to figure out what the locus
is
it is again a homologue of arabidopsis
in the hissing Gene
at that Locus it is the the stringless
beings have a duplication
combined with an insertion of a
retrotransposon in between the two
copies
that creates an increased expression
and it eliminates the string
now at the same time this duplication
creates an instability
to an equal recombination you can revert
at a high frequency about one in a
thousand you can revert to these string
strings stringy state
and so we are still looking at what is
how can we deal with this to increase
the stability but it's a major issue in
terms of quality control and maintenance
of genetic stocks in the uh in in the
green bean industry the production of
oil varieties and they spend some kind
of fifty thousand dollars we don't know
for sure we're trying to guess
uh every year just because they have to
send down people through the fields to
Rogue the the revertence at the same
time these revertents are excellent
isogenic lines because you have the
original state and the reverton state in
the nisogeneous state yeah so we seek we
we are sequencing them as well but again
it illustrates how these domestication
traits are still important today
and one of the questions is what is the
equivalent of these genes the hopalog in
these other physiologist domesticated
species okay
so I have to introduce temporary Bean to
you and lima bean these are the
seedlings you see in the field to the
left
is uh
a temporary Bean seedling
you see here
and this is a lima bean season
um
this is what they look in the field at
the left you see common being at the
right is temporary beam it's a very
branched growth habit prostrate hugging
the soils
you think that it's part maybe of the
adaptation we see the same thing in
common being in the
ecogeographic ways Durango for northern
Mexico where it's dry they also have
this prostrate habit and also
interestingly in the anion domestication
raised Chile also has these prostate
growth habits because presumably because
of the dry environment
uh there is also a difference in the
earliness
to the left you see common Bean it's
still green the dry patches are these
mature cenest uh temporary beans
and then to the right here is Lima B so
there are differences in the average
cycle
clearly temperament is the shortest as
the shortest cycle which is part of that
tolerance to terminal drought
you have to run your cycle as quickly as
possible to escape the droughts at the
end of the cycle
this is what the seeds look like the
scale here is centimeters these are
photos of the gene bank at seat which
systematically takes photos of the seeds
and the PODS of their Holdings
and you see overall
the seeds are fairly small then that is
an issue with the consumers okay
and our Gene Banks you have the USDA as
Holdings seat Hillary in Africa as a
potential forage
and you see that
branched growth habits here
but also Australia in Brazil
most of the wild types the orange dots
they're distributed like I said in the
Northwest Quadrant of Mexico but also
spilling over into Arizona and then the
domesticated types in purple have a
slightly broader distribution but not
that Broad and then there are
differences among the wild populations
in terms of their adaptation to Drought
you have types here near at the stream
edges
but then going up the slope and their
leaves also change
um the ones that are up to slopes are in
dry conditions and they have smaller
leaves or smaller evaporative surface
so this was a collaborative trial with
seat uh
and Nebraska Carlos
udea who is the bean breeder in the
Panhandle in western Nebraska
and
myself and Jorge Bernie is a student
here in Davis and Santos Barrera he's
the person from seat who was kind of
central to these comparative
um
experiments
and then heat stress trials here were
conducted then both in California the
university has these really
unappreciated series of experiment
station kind of north south along the
state and they have very diverse
environment and one here is that the
so-called desert research and Extension
Center with the board of Mexico
in the summer it's
to quote stinking hot
and that's what we want
and we had done a preliminary experiment
growing common Bean lima bean and
temporary Bean common being was killed
and the only the two species that
survived were lima bean and temporary
beam okay so we had done a preliminary
experiment
but then they also conducted experiments
um
in um in Colombia you know the northern
coast near the Caribbean uh very hot and
humid this time uh and then Alvarado in
one of the The Valleys of the Magdalena
river which can also be very hot
the results of this analysis then if you
compare
UC Davis and another station West
the West Side research and Extension
Center the three species here commonly
in temporary being the non-babina color
products so you see the green ones are
common beans
and this graph then shows uh well
irrigated and drought and you see a
fairly good correlation but
common being is the least adapted
to this situation
then comes the lima bean in red
and then in blue is separating
and clearly there are tremendous marked
species differences as well as
intra-specific differences in their
yields
I will highlight here the step varieties
these are actually bread lines these are
not just giant plasm land races
and tap is actually a product
led by Tim Porsche
some of you may know Tim porch he's a
graduate of Cornell Okay so
it shows on one hand that yes we can use
the land races but breeding will add to
the the tolerance of the distributions
there has been almost no breeding in
that species
met stands for multi-environment trials
and you see here an analysis just of
temporary being under heat stress and
under drought stress and the two
combined fairly High correlation but
again these tap materials come out on
top here so there is room for breeding
um in in this species
and the same thing here where you look
at the yield which the Improvement
improved lines figure here as the
highest
highest yielders in this situation
now one of the things that is
interesting here is that you know at
each of these locations we grow them
underground in the well water conditions
and you might ask well do these how do
they group these locations and these
treatments you could say well all the
drought stressed materials will group on
one side and the well watered on the
other side
or is it going to be grouped according
to location and what turns out is that a
group rather based on location rather
than treated within location
to me it suggests that we don't
completely know what is adaptation
we treat them here in terms of broadly
speaking the general temperature the
general rainfall or the the amount of
water supplied during the experiment but
that is not enough
there must be other characters involved
in adaptation besides these few simple
ones here I don't have an answer to that
question what is it that really
differentiates these locations what you
see here is this is UC Davis
this is Alvarado in Colombia high
temperature
this is Palmira also in Colombia drought
and irrigated
okay so you see here the pattern that
the different treatments tend to group
together it's really separated by
location
it's not a new observation really but it
it raises that question of
we need to know more about it
now
temporary Bean has been of interest to
people in common being because they see
it as a source of genetic diversity and
particularly resistance to Common being
resistant to common bacterial blood in
common being
and that has been transferred to show
you and people have developed over about
I would say 20 25 years from near
absence of resistance in common being
two fairly high levels of resistance by
combining different sources including
the resistance in equity folios in
temporary
and the the intention is then to combine
this also with tolerance to heat and
tolerance to gratitude
whether that's going to be possible is
depends I think the common B the common
bacterial blight resistance was in
essence an easy case
it's a major Gene trait in temporary
beam although it's more complex in
common being but it was a they were able
to do it using acrobatics which I will
explain
drought tolerance we almost showed that
it's a genetically more complex traits
now but the point I would like to make
here
the emphasis is always transferring
generic diversity from temporary B to
Common B but what about the opposite
let's take this adaptation
to heat and drought in temporary bead
and build February beam as another crop
and
I think people start turning around with
that but the emphasis has always still
been improved in common
my points in this talk is yes we should
be able to do both
and even if the situation
persists really improves Library being
as a source as a brain building
so
pepper we've been here
is a domesticate that has domesticated
things wild types it can be trusted with
extreme difficulty
okay and people have to use
embryo culture and so on
the natives actually cannot be crossed
to vulgaris and the other species that
has been determined
so this is I would say gene24
um
well temporary Bean is gene pool three
but the reciprocally between common
being and B so that's an issue to take
into account
um
we have done whole genome sequences
sequencing of uh land races breeding
materials in common being
including these genetic stocks that are
resistant
what you see here the organization of
genetic diversity so you have
the 11 chromosomes from 1 to 11.
the blue
so the blue color represents an anion
origin after the chromosome the part of
the chromosome
and so these block of lines here from A
and D to
nabe nabe 14 these are typically Andean
domesticates
on the other hand the red or pink lines
from ALB
to vac 6 are typically Mesoamerican
domesticates
and you see that there is some
introgression maybe asymmetric if you
have more integration for mesoamerica to
the Andy and group and that is because
of reading one wanted to introduce
disease resistance
okay
nevertheless we see a few other
inter-specific introgressions and the
one from temporary Bean here is
typically at the end of chromosomes
I don't know exactly why but we have
noticed that disease resistance clusters
are usually at the end of chromosomes
and that may be because there is higher
recombination there
and the recombination creates genetic
diverse
uh
faced which could face the variability
of the pathogen
but it's also maybe easier to introgress
a material in a high recombination
region than in a low recombination
region
that clearly is a caveat in terms of the
future in terms of introdressing these
different traits
okay so it says we need to have larger
populations maybe to identify rare
recombinants
so the contribution here of
Santos
who although he got his degree at
Nebraska he came two summers to Davis to
help to also screen these materials
um
what he did
was
to cross an inter-specific inbred line
the I and b834
with a wild relative of tapiribi the
parvifolius
which is
been relabeled recently but it's let's
say Harvey polius so you have vulgaris
acotifolius
and Harvey folias so they call this the
VAP lines
and
give you the
comparison if you cross vulgaris bike
with portfolios you have to make tons of
crosses you see the
the labels to the left here of the
failed crosses
if on the other hand you cross this line
to part of the folders you have a
relatively High success rate and this is
just a visual comparison
but you get then
seeds that will develop
for a normal vulgaris by temporary being
across you have to do an Embryo Embryo
culture to retrieve anything at all
right
so it is easier to cross
this vulgaris containing hybrid in red
line with Harvey folios
and you see them here the developing
embryo
and you see a plantlet
and eventually fall plant here
now this line is still sterile but if
you back cross it to vulgaris you get a
progeny
so if you compare the normal
common B by teporin being crossed the
number of f1s that he obtained in spite
of the large number of
um
large number of crosses was maybe 20 and
compare comparison the cross of these
that lines by temporary Bean you could
you could obtain a large number 10-fold
increase in the number of graduates
the number of PODS was also larger
um and
um
in spite of having a lower number of
pollinations
so
these VAP lines what they have allowed
us to do is to cross vulgaris
with temporary being at a much higher
rate than normal
basically initially Crossing vulgaria's
and aquatifolios was low viability low
fertility
so somewhere in that genome there must
be segments of horizontaliers that allow
increased success rate in the process we
don't know what the engineers are it's
an empirical observation right
these lines have been sequenced
you see here the reference genome which
is an engine reference genome you have
an aquatifolius
genome
this is a Mesoamerican genome and then
you have these VAP lines these Bridge
lines and inter-specific golgaris
and so they looked at the number of
Harvey folius
segments
that were transferred to the progeny in
in these VAP lines and you see a much
higher frequency here compared to
these inter-specific vulgaris values
and I
like to remind you these VAP lines are
also interspecific but they involve a
third species and so you have a higher
rate of transmission in these VAP lines
there is also
heterozygosity and that may be a problem
in maintenance
okay
so you see the comparison so this again
is the sequencing
the light blue is
common being
common being a genome
but then you have introgressions the
purple and the brown here from
aquitophobius and so large segments so
still there is an issue of recombination
but these VAP lines have an increased
introdression of equity folios or
parsifolius
um
segments in a chromosome
so Santos then wanted to test out
if it made any difference in terms of
drug tolerance
and so by Crossing
these VAP lines with that building as a
source of drought tolerance
you get a hybrid which you back cross
to equity folios this is what it looks
like
um then backwash it to vulgaris
another backrest
this is what it looks like and you see
the parts here there is no evidence
really
marked the evidence of sterility okay
So eventually he did then test the
progeny and you have these interspecific
lines that result from the cross between
VAP lines and acutifolios and then
controls you have the VAP lines
themselves you have common Bean lines
you have these inter-specific models by
temporary lines
I think I'm running out of time
yeah okay and uh so let me show you the
results of this
um
it then perform drought and heat
stressed trials
and what you see is that the progeny
lines you can identify these are in the
squares you see progeny lines
that are have better yields more
significantly higher yields under
drought uh in in two years actually
no so his interpretation is that we are
successful in transferring some of that
drought tolerance into lines of common
being that themselves are already high
more tolerant to drought and what the
fields you see here the comparison
between for example
the original fulgers
and this is the process involving this
three-way across with Barbie folios
I'll skip
a few our conclusion is from other
studies is that aquatifolius is for
terminal resistance uh terminal drought
and Lima beam is actually for
intermittent drought
I'll uh
we are also working on lima bean and
what you see here is we developed a
large-scale
um
a large-scale recombinant inbred
population that was useful in developing
a
developing a reference genome in Lima
Bean with Colombian researchers and then
mapping
several traits on the left
you have determinacy in the same
chromosome location as in common being
you have 100 seed weight which shows
additive pattern
flowering time also heavily determined
by determinacy and then cyanogenesis
which shows epistatic interaction
and the final thoughts here is that if
we want to increase the the use of Gene
Banks we have to be involved in
pre-breeding
like the experiments in crossability
uh but also
um the testing John plasm conversion
using these domestication traits to
introduce them into an adapted germ
plans which is kind of the opposite way
that we
and finally
I would
acknowledge these three people
because they are going to take over the
green breeding program the East Africa
program and also we have a group looking
at the physiology and the drought with
Matthew Gilbert and so I can retire
happily well I won't be retiring let me
tell you because I'll be working on that
lima bean project with the scri in the
USDA but at least some somewhat
alleviated and I'm very grateful for
these individuals for continuing to
listen but I'm sorry so I'm running a
little bit out thank you very much
and and of course you know Christine
that was the purpose of the slide
thank you I was wondering if your map
lines already showed some kind of
agronomically or agriculturally
improvements in terms of drought stress
or really just better possibility with
the temporary
I think that the fact that they have
viability fertility if they survive in
the field we think that it's a big
progress
but it's not the final detail
that's the pre-breeding that's
there have to be next steps
yeah
you have to realize what it was that's
why I showed that that's that slide with
all the labels and so on you know they
just
you try you try you find they fall off
and they fall off
so it having something that is viable
and fertile is already a big problem
yes
there's one gene that is
every Variety in North America has to
have that is the hygiene or resist
immunity I think for resistance to give
common mosaic virus
it has reached a stage where people
cross Elite by Elite in common being in
North America well they don't even have
to screen for it because the two parents
have it and the progenies sociology
that definitely is the case then the
other might be some of the consumer
traits the seed size at least reach
something that is like a navy bean or a
black bean we have the colors already
but the seed size could be larger
and others yeah so that one we are
looking now at uh pot shattering we
don't think that it's a problem because
it comes from a dry area
but
we are looking at the the genetic basis
of
so I'm sure that once you start growing
the diseases and pests will find their
way to the field
then
then it's wide open
um even so far
is it very specifically
it's getting now over and narrow
so they are in competition with other
places in the country
so common being as disappeared
used to be but then it's competing with
North Dakota Michigan and so on
so it's now lima bean
uh Black Eyed Pea Okapi and garbanzios
and garbanzos get planted in the early
winter
as a winter crop because the others is
seen as a summer crop but then in
California they're also in competition
with
um these trees not trees
and I don't understand that because
these are going to be in water
I expect them to start complaining that
they don't get enough water
why would you plant a tree but that's
what they do so the the I think the
economics is whatever
yields or brings in most money per unit
area
that's the thing
oh yes so you're saying that uh at the
beginning Lima beam is more of a water
user versus the uh temporary beans are a
lot of paper yeah so could you highlight
more on maybe
the water user part of lima beans is
there anything you've been able to learn
from the water saver beads essentially
trying is it just really just the
growing season and that's why the
difference of the length
yeah actually in a sense everybody is
not that different from common being
except for the fact that it accelerates
its growth under stress so it has this
plasticity but you really if you used to
work if you walk the fields say hey I've
beaten up on this temporary beam and it
grows faster and bigger yeah
but lima bean but I think it's
distinctive Treatise is that it has lots
of biomass and including a very deep
root system
and so under heat stress the leaf
temperature is lower than what you've
seen come and Bean or even better
think that it is because of evaporation
uh that cools off the the mechanical
and because of that deeper system
and we have seen the same thing in Wild
common being when we you can use wild
common being to
improve yield under stress these are the
the populations that do that come from
dry areas in Mexico the driest areas in
Mexico they also have the deepest food
system
it's not a strong correlation but it's
10 percent
I'm satisfied with interesting because
what is adaptation it's probably a
multitude of Trades
so there is not one trait that is
incisive
and so these wild beans they reshape
their root system if you impose a stress
equal amounts of
[Music]
um
biomass they get deeper and less
branched root systems
what made you do you know the legume
that has a really high level of three
amino acids
[Music]
they have the highest they have the
highest digestive dog essentially and
two to three people more than approach
I'm sorry
I could maybe understand why they would
have digestibility they don't have to
cleave those proteins right yeah yeah
but the question is they may also have
three non-protein amino acids
yeah you know there's lots of amino
acids they're not necessarily the
protein amino acid so are they really
nutritional positive or negative factors
right it seems like there are some amino
acids that
I don't know I
I'm trying to go to the depths of my
library
I would be careful with that yeah
I
yeah I won't say anything
what I meant to say is that the yield
pattern among these standard set of
lines is determined
is grouped by location not by the
treatment
and a priority you could say well I'm
going to have all the the drought
treatments on one side and I'll do the
well waters on the other side no it's
actually said it's root by location
and Nebraska seemed to be quite
different we thought oh it's a fairly
dry environment we're going to resemble
California maybe no no it's very
separate thing so there must be other
factors
involved
and it's really asking the question to
try to find an answer to draw the
attention to people is that how do we
characterize an environment
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu